[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily the
Pike County Massacre jurors get a
first-hand look at several crime scenes
and the only fans model accused of
murdering her boyfriend pleads not
guilty to the crime plus R Kelly's
defense team argues his Federal sex
crimes charges should be dropped and
later the Parkland school shooter
penalty phase trial how the gunman
reacted after breakdowns he had as a
child when he calmed down he was extreme
you could see he he really was
apologetic about what he did almost like
it was another person that had done it
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
foreign
welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber in for Brian buckmeyer
jurors visit the scenes of The Pike
County Massacre days before opening
statements are set to be presented in
the trial of George Wagner IV Wagner
faces eight counts of aggravated murder
in connection to the 2016 deaths of the
rodent in Gilly families prosecutors say
Angela Wagner George Billy Wagner III
Edward Jake Wagner and George Wagner IV
killed eight people all in an effort to
obtain sole custody of Jake's daughter
Jake and Angela Wagner both confessed to
planning the murders and expected to
testify against George Wagner IV the
defendant maintains he didn't shoot
anyone but faces the death penalty if
convicted a jury made of nine women and
three men was seated this week six
alternate jurors will also be chosen
before opening statements are presented
next Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday of
this week a reserve for the jury to view
multiple locations associated with the
crime jurors will see where members of
the rodent and Gilly families were
murdered and where the Wagner families
lived before their arrests joining us
today is co-host Terry Austin and law
professor Kirk Burkhalter it's great to
have you both here Professor I'll start
with you you have four members of One
family allegedly conspiring to kill
eight people over a child custody battle
so the question is how important is it
to determine who actually pulled the
triggers
well in some respects it's not important
in that the conspiratives
co-conspirators can be convicted of the
ultimate crime even if they didn't pull
the trigger so we collaborate together
we all have the same couple mental state
and so forth doesn't matter who pull the
trigger everyone is liable for the
murder however
there's a causation issue and juries
like to have the loop closed so it's
sometimes it's difficult to obtain a
conviction you know it's like trying to
obtain a conviction for instance if
there's no body right you know showing
up so juries like to know who pulled the
trigger or how the ultimate Act was uh
committed and the causation is one of
the elements of the crime so uh if the
prosecution cannot make those links do
run the risk of an acquittal now Terry
you might think you know people might
think oh the prosecution's got a slam
dunk case but what happens if Jake and
Angela have conflicting testimonies how
are the prosecutors going to know who's
telling the truth that's going to be
very interesting Jesse if they don't
have the same story they're going to
have to rely on forensic evidence
they're going to look at cell phone data
they're going to look at DNA they're
going to look at ballistics and I think
with that cooperating evidence they'll
be able to determine which of them if
they say can you know conflicting
stories which of them is telling this
truth but you know they both had plea
deals Jake had a plea deal first and
then Angela's deal came later but they
both had a deal that said if they told
the truth and they assist it with the
conviction then everyone would not have
the death penalty so it behooves them to
get their story straight and if they're
telling the truth it shouldn't be that
difficult to get the story straight so
I'm very interested to see what they're
going to say if they're going to point
the finger at each other or at others
the other two and so we'll see but
hopefully they they tell the truth and
uh they'll avoid the death penalty all
right we'll wait and see how it
ultimately shakes up because that's
going to be a a trial to watch we move
over now to Texas where several news
organizations are suing officials in
Uvalde after months of refusing to
release records related to the massacre
at Rob Elementary School in May the
lawsuit against the city the County
Sheriff's Office and the school district
comes after dozens of Public Information
Act requests seeking body cam footage
911 phone calls surveillance footage
video and communication between local
leaders on May 24th an 18 year old
gunman shot and killed 19 students and
two teachers before being fatally shot
by police the response to the massacre
came under intense scrutiny when it came
to light that law enforcement waited
over an hour before entering the school
and classroom a special committee found
several systemic failures among the
response and protocols a nearly 80-page
report revealed almost 400 officers
responded to the scene and that it took
more than 70 seven minutes to breach the
classroom and kill the gunman law
enforcement has since refused to release
any more records related to the shooting
saying there's a pending investigation
but the lawsuit argues there's no
criminal investigation since the shooter
who's now dead acted alone
attorneys for disgraced South Carolina
attorney Alec Murdoch say that they've
received an order compelling State
prosecutors to hand over evidence
against their client in the 2021
shooting deaths of his wife and son this
comes two days after a hearing on Monday
in which a judge ordered the discovery
be handed over to Murdoch's defense team
part of that order also includes a
temporary protective order keeping
evidence the state says led to Murdoch's
arrest private well at least for now
Murdoch faces two murder charges in the
shooting deaths of his wife Maggie and
Son Paul he was charged last month more
than a year after they were killed on
the property of their home over the last
few weeks Murdoch's attorneys filed
motions accusing the state of failing to
turn over to the evidence which led to
those charges and leaking evidence to
family in the media but those aren't
Murdoch's only legal issues he's facing
around 90 counts of alleged fraud
related charges he's accused of scamming
former clients out of millions of
dollars and being involved in alleged
drug trafficking scheme
and officials make an arrest of a marine
veteran who's been on the run for six
years after Raymond MacLeod allegedly
killed his new girlfriend Crystal
Mitchell officials say McLeod fled the
U.S immediately after Mitchell was found
beaten to death while the couple was
visiting friends in San Diego in June of
2016. they believed that he had possibly
gone through Mexico to Central America
last year the search for McLeod ramped
up making the 30 year old the first ever
fugitive on the Marshall service 15 most
wanted list with a fifty thousand dollar
reward the Marine vet was previously an
avid bodybuilder and a heavy drinker
this according to authorities they also
said that he had a history of domestic
violence while on the Run officials
tracked his location through several
countries including Belize in Guatemala
now six years later McLeod was captured
in El Salvador after officials received
a tip that he had been teaching English
at a school there he will be deported to
San Diego to face charges
and still ahead on Long Prime Deli the
defense will soon begin its case as R
Kelly stands trial for federal sex
crimes but first the attorneys appear in
court on behalf of only fans model and
Instagram influencer Courtney clenny as
she pleads to murder charges in the
April stabbing death of her boyfriend
[Music]
and welcome back everybody only fans
model and Instagram influencer Courtney
klenny pleads not guilty through her
attorney in a Miami hearing over the
stabbing death of her boyfriend
Christian Toby obamselli clenny is
charged with second-degree murder
accused of stabbing obamselli with a
kitchen knife in their luxury Florida
Apartment back in April she was
initially questioned over the incident
but while released officials
investigated after clinty claimed she
threw the knife at obamacelli stabbing
him in self-defense prosecutors say
forensic evidence though didn't support
this and that the medical examiner
determined he was stabbed at close range
they say clenny was the aggressor in the
relationship which was reportedly
continuously abusive Lenny was arrested
in Hawaii three weeks ago and extradited
to Florida on Friday plenty wasn't
present for the very short hearing
Wednesday morning but her attorney
entered a not guilty plea on the model's
behalf a trial date was set for December
well Terry the defendant claiming
self-defense here do you think that she
has to prove that their her boyfriend
had this History of Violence that she
was the victim is that necessary for
this case
I think it's very necessary especially
since they have videos of her attacking
him apparently they had a very
tumultuous relationship but it is
unclear overall who was the initial
aggressor for most of those arguments
that video footage I think is going to
help the prosecution he's trying to
restrain her he's trying to defend
himself and she's the one who is
violently attacking him so one of the
things I was wondering about in this
case is why it took so long to actually
arrest her the police arrested her and
put her in handcuffs at the time of the
incident but then let her go and she was
able to go to Hawaii apparently she said
she was doing some PTSD but it is very
unclear to me why under these
circumstances they didn't charge her
earlier on she was literally soaked in
blood so we'll have to see what happens
at the end of the day but it does seem
as though she's the one who caused the
initial problems in that relationship
well Professor it seems that they
initially believed her story right so
she claimed she threw the knife at
obamacelli from 10 feet away as I said
the Emmy's office is saying he died from
a forceful downward thrust is there any
way you could throw a knife and it could
be a forceful downward thrust
well is there a way there's always a way
somewhere but most of those folks are
employed by the circus all right so if
you think about it first of all a
kitchen knife is not a balanced
instrument that is made for throwing
that's number one if you look at her
musculature I don't see her as being
strong enough to throw a knife with that
much force and does she have the
expertise to hit her Target finally
mentioned downward thrust the knife
would have to be thrown in such a way
and travel in such an arc I have so much
force that it would enter the body in a
downward motion coming from someone who
is much uh shorter than the victim so
the story seems quite incredible I don't
think it's going to fly and her defense
is going to have to explain that away
somehow we'll continue to follow that
case I want to move over to California
though in the trial of Paul and Ruben
Flores jurors hear from investigators
who search the home of one of the
defendants years after The Disappearance
and death of Cal Poly student Kristen
smart smart went missing after a part 30
26 years ago in may of 1996 but the case
went cold that is until the Father and
Son were arrested last year following
several searches of their homes
Witnesses say Paul who was charged with
her murder was the last person to be
seen with smart when he walked her home
from the party Paul's father Reuben is
charged with accessory after the fact
for allegedly helping hide the body and
allegedly burying her in his backyard
and later moving the remains a detective
testified to getting permission to
wiretap the phones of the Flores family
back in 2020. a conversation between
Paul and his mother was played for the
jurors in which he told Paul to listen
to the podcast your own backyard which
was following the investigation so they
could start punching holes in it a
former deputy sheriff testified before
that recording was played saying the
department had leaked information to the
podcast which is credited with
reigniting interest in the case after it
began in late 2019.
coming up on Long crime daily the
defense continues its case in the
Parkland school shooter penalty phase
trial plus R Kelly's defense team calls
for federal charges to be thrown out
just one day before this team is set to
start calling Witnesses
[Music]
now welcome back R Kelly's defense team
begins its case by asking for an
acquittal as the convicted sex offender
and disgrace singer stands trial for
federal sex crimes after 10 days of
testimony with more than 25 Witnesses
called the prosecution rested its case
on Monday this comes as the 55-year-old
singer stands trial in Illinois for 13
Federal sex crimes charges in 2008 Kelly
was acquitted by a Cook County Illinois
jury for creating a video of himself
having sex with a 14 year old girl now
at the time the girl and her parents
denied involvement and they didn't
testify but this time around the alleged
victim and her mother testified saying
they lied out of fear for their safety
as part of the prosecution's case jurors
heard from four accusers who said Kelly
abused them as minors on Wednesday the
defense presented a motion for an
acquittal saying the prosecution failed
to show Kelly
specifically sought to receive child
pornography the defense is expected to
call its first witness on Thursday
Professor the defense asking for an
acquittal you know on one hand you might
be thinking oh they're just doing this
for the record on the other might be
thinking well maybe they got a point
maybe they have a way maybe there's a
point for an acquittal here what do you
think
well it's an interesting move usually
this type of motion comes at the end of
trial whenever evidence or the evidence
is produced it's a as a matter of law
claiming that the prosecution doesn't
have uh enough evidence or the evidence
doesn't fulfill the uh requirements
under the law I think number one nothing
to lose here more than likely uh you
know things are not going to go in R
Kelly's favor he's already been
convicted so why not try it and then
further just gives them one more
opportunity to preserve issues uh for
the appeal so I don't think they're
going to be successful however it's just
a tactic to uh to give to give it a try
and try to get them off well Terry now
that the defense case is underway okay
and putting aside the motion for
acquittal the big question I have is is
Kelly going to testify because right now
his attorneys are staying they're still
mulling it over
you know I cannot believe they're
mulling it over what is there to mull
over if they're having a conversation
with Kelly I am sure they are trying to
tell him no you don't want to get on the
stand oftentimes defendants want to get
on the stand to tell their story and
usually it's a defendant who is somewhat
arrogant and thinks that he needs to
speak out although obviously every
defendant has the right to speak on
their own behalf but I think it's the
most dangerous in this type of situation
because he's been accused of raping
individuals under the age of 18 hundreds
of times those women have testified to
that so what is he going to say when he
gets on that stand and he has
cross-examination and they're asking
about those instances and remember the
jury probably knows about that New York
conviction that Kirk referred to and if
they know about it and they're listening
to him on the stand I think he's not
going to seem credible hey he might want
to tell a story we all remember his CBS
interview this is a guy that was very
vocal then maybe he'll be vocal another
time we'll have to wait and see when we
come back a closer look at the Parkland
School Shooter's childhood hear from a
neighbor of the gunman who says his
adoptive mother was not responsive to
calls for help
[Music]
and welcome back everybody as the
defense continues its case in the
Parkland school shooter penalty phase
trial jurors here from the defendant's
neighbor who describes violent outbursts
during his childhood in February 2018
and then 19 year old gunman opened fire
at Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School
killing 17 people and injuring 17 others
last year that gunman pleaded guilty to
all counts it's now up to a Florida jury
to decide whether he receives life in
prison or the death penalty the defense
began its case just last week largely
focusing on the defendant's rocky
childhood including a biological mother
who used drugs and alcohol while
pregnant and an adoptive mother who
ignored his cries for help on Wednesday
jurors heard from Paul gold this is a
neighbor who knew the gunman as a child
he testified the defendant had sudden
outbursts but seemed truly sorry after a
meltdown
were there other things that you saw
sort of triggered these episodes in May
it was almost
I'd have to say they were almost
spontaneous and out of nowhere when he
he would lose his temper one time he
took a golf club and and smashed a small
motorcycle trailer that I had
you know just out of nowhere I I
remember exactly what caused him to be
so angry but I don't think it was
anything and after he did that he came
over and was you know profusely
apologetic and that was kind of
his routine he would be very nice very
sociable not sociable but very
very pleasant to people and you know
wanting wanting to be nice to people and
then another moment when he would lose
his temper he would just break things
and go off you know off like seen that
of his mind and then when he calmed down
he was extra you could see he really he
really was apologetic about what he did
almost like it was another person that
had done it
um gold also discussed his relationship
with the defendant's adoptive mother
Linda Cruz
I think you mentioned that at some point
you told Linda that you were worried I
told her immediately when I met him okay
like the first time I met him I I knew
he needed some some serious help
I knew that this kid was was not right
you know psychologically that
seem to have developmental issues he had
lots of signs of kids that that need to
have you know that he need to have some
some
you know supervised help or some kind of
psychological counseling or something
did uh how do you remember how Linda
responded to that suggestion by you she
was very mad she was very angry she said
there's nothing wrong with her son he's
fine and
that was it I didn't mention it again it
really
was disconcerting for her
Professor what's interesting about his
testimony is that before he testified
the parties agreed that he wouldn't
testify as a psychological expert even
though he had some medical background
what would Council need to do or need to
demonstrate for this witness to be
qualified as an expert
so that's a great question I don't want
to testify as an expert the witness has
to possess some type of skill knowledge
expertise or education and certainly the
witness here falls into that category
however uh the opinion has to be based
on some form of reli the product of
reliable methods in this case in order
to be qualified as an expert Not only
would they have to put into evidence as
educational background but it's the
methodology that's important he would
have to have examined records perhaps
examine the defendant as a psychologist
not as a neighbor and a late person so
they would have had to jump through
those extra Hoops in order to get him
qualified as an expert with this and
maybe it's not necessary because Terry
I'm going to ask you overall he was a
defense witness he was called for a
reason how do you understand
you know that prosecutor mopped the
floor with him as far as I'm concerned I
think that jury looked at Paul gold and
said you are just making things up first
of all on Direct he said that Linda
should have gotten Nick help but the
prosecution on Cross made it very clear
that Linda did get him help at the age
of three years old and Pogo had no idea
about that so he clearly didn't know
what he was talking about and he looked
as though he was you know definitely not
knowledgeable about what was going on in
their lives then he said that she was
overprotective but she was starving the
kids and the prosecution was able to
show those are not consistent if she was
overprotective why would she starve the
kids and I think the biggest point they
made was the fact that he separated from
Linda because of some argument over an
iPad and yet he remained in contact with
Nicholas Cruz and he called him in jail
right and you know that was just a
horrible situation you would think the
defense would be better prepared but you
know not not sitting in that chair Terry
Professor thank you so much everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on Long
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss Justice in America
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]